hello mr. kubernetes hi there
have a new pod version for you to deploy
oh just leave it right there I need to
rebalance this network traffic between
these two pods well it looks like you
have your hands full over there trying
to do my job it'd be really nice to get
some help with all this network traffic
you know what I think I have just the
thing
it's called sto can you please show it
to me
the steel helps you manage and
understand the interactions and network
communication between microservices in
your environment it is completely open
source can be deployed in and across
multiple environments whether you're
working with virtual machines or
containers with an Orchestrator like
kubernetes and consists of a number of
components that when deployed in your
environment transparently layer on top
of your distributed application to allow
you to do things like monitoring and
load-balancing without any code changes
in this short walkthrough we'll see how
we can use SEO to do very fine-grained
traffic routing in a distributed
application deployed on kubernetes this
becomes useful when deploying a busy
application with patterns like canary or
Bluegreen deployments I have a cluster
running on google kubernetes engine and
I've already configured it to ensure
that any pod I deploy into my cluster
uses Sto so I'm going to be able to
monitor and control the traffic to and
from these pods for free without any
code changes currently running on this
cluster I have a very simple application
that consists of two services the first
service is the UI service this service
is responsible for rendering and serving
the user interface upon request from the
outside world I have another service
called the color service which specifies
the color of particular UI components so
before the UI service can render and
serve the page it has to consult the
color service to know what colors to use
taking a look at the pods we should see
that I only have one pod serving the UI
service and four pods serving the color
service now suppose you want to roll out
a new version of the color service but
you don't want to go all in but want to
roll it out gradually in control stages
for example you have a second version of
my color service that I want to deploy
you could use kubernetes deployments for
that you create another deployment label
it appropriately so that's included in
the same load balance group as a v1
service and then gradually change the
ratio of V 2 parts to V 1 pods to rather
desired amount of traffic to either
version so let's go ahead and deploy
that v2 service and we can verify that
it was deployed successfully and here we
can see we have 1 v2 part and for v1
pods now when I go to my application I
see my UI is deeply displaying a blue
button the color is coming from my v1
service but as i refresh the bottom
multiple times I see a green button ok
which is coming from a v2 color service
and this happens about roughly 20% of
the time now the limitation of this
approach is that the only way to control
the percentage of traffic that goes to
either pod is by directly scaling each
version up or down so if you only want
to 10% traffic to hit your v2 part you
have to have nine v1 pods and 1 v2 pod
this tree allows us to decouple this and
shifts traffic from one version to
another independently of the number of
replicas for either service it co
introduced as a resource called a
virtual service which allows me to do
that to deploy a virtual service i
specify how much traffic i want to go to
each service and the virtual service
resource will ensure these proportions
are honored expectable how many pods
each service actually present so taking
a look here I have a virtual service
defined that is configured to send 100%
of traffic to my V one part and none to
the v2 service now we can deploy this
configuration and actually test that
this is the case and when I switch to my
application I can see that no matter how
many times i refresh I always get served
the blue button that's my v1 service now
if I go back to my configuration I can
switch this I can route 90% of my
traffic to my v1 service and 10% of the
traffic's of v2 service and if I deploy
this again we should see a predictable
result roughly 10% of requests will get
sold a green button and the rest the 90%
will get served a blue button taking
this further I can switch the weights to
50/50 so 50% of traffic to the v1
service 50% of traffic to the v2 service
deployed this change and if I go back to
the application
I should see roughly every other time
the button is either blue or green and
then finally I can route a hundred
percent of my traffic to the v2 service
and zero percent of traffic to the v1
service apply that change and if I go
back to my application I should always
get served the green button and going
back to our deployments just to verify
that the races are still the same we
should still see only one v2 pod and for
v1 pods
so using Sto you really get a
deep level of control over how your
traffic is routed across your
microservices hey mister kubernetes
you're looking a little better Thank You
Jonathan so much for showing me sto I
now spend my day making sure my services
are up and I don't have to play traffic
cop anymore that's right
using SEO gives you a lot of control
over that traffic with a lot more ease
exactly don't forget to Like comment and
subscribe and if you're working on a
cool project and would like to get in
contact with us please click on the link
in the description thanks for watching
[Music]